[Musique]
oh
la voix de malika tirolien qui joue les
thèmes avec moi donc il ya cet élément
donc d'humanité qui passe à travers la
voix humaine forcément
[Musique]
au lieu d'avoir deux kg un cas et une
batterie parce que depuis soneca là un
beau coup du langage du gros qu'un a été
transférée donc de la percussion à la
batterie à travers le travail de deux
combattants
[Musique]
tous
lorsque je joue de la soul music
lorsque je joue du jazz américain ou
lorsque je joue deux du jazz plus
européen j'arrive complètement et
pleinement avec mon langage mon langage
qui est ancré dans dans la musique
vaudou dans l'agro cas dans le bled
anthony ces musiques qui font partie de
notre héritage
[Musique]
e